nature can be really quiet
or really loud
it can even be musical we hear
sound almost everywhere on earth but
what about sounds
from space despite what you might hear
in science fiction movies
you can't hear any sound in space but
what if we found a way
to listen to the stars especially our
sun
how loud is the sun how could we listen
to it
and what would the sun sound like
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could hear
the sun even though we can't hear it
since sound doesn't travel through the
vacuum of space
the sun is incredibly loud the immense
power
emanating from its core produces sonic
waves that travel and bounce around
inside it
scientists aren't exactly sure how loud
the sun is
but they estimate that there would be at
least 200 watts of sound power
for every square meter this would be the
equivalent of
320 decibels which is so loud that
it would kill you think of it being like
an opera singer shattering a glass but
in this case you're the glass
our atmosphere here on earth provides a
medium for sound waves to be heard
if a crow cause or a cat meows these
sound waves produce vibrations in the
air molecules around us
forming frequencies that vibrate in our
eardrums
even though space lacks an atmosphere to
transmit
sound there are still particles within
the plasma of space that
can be affected by sound these ripples
of energy are known as
magnetosonic waves like sound they
are pressure waves but they're also
magnetic
they're also very small and quiet around
minus 100 decibels
to put this into perspective a normal
conversation
is about 60 decibels so we would need
eardrums
the size of earth to hear these waves
okay so
maybe having giant eardrums isn't the
best way to listen to the sun
so how else could we hear it immense
clouds of hot gas
rising from inside the sun and traveling
at speeds
over 160 000 kilometers an hour
produce ripples on the sun's surface and
if you've ever passed gas yourself you
know
that other people can hear it so you
won't be surprised that
all that gas makes the sun noisy too
but since we can't hear it how can we
measure it
the sonic ripples on the sun's surface
cause changes in the frequency of light
giving scientists an accurate picture of
what's going on within the sun
scientists can measure these light
frequencies and translate them into
sound waves
using a doppler graph on the solar and
heliospheric observatory spacecraft
this process of turning information into
sound
is called sonification just as an
ambulance's siren
changes pitch as it passes by us the
frequencies of light
rippling across the sun change color
based on the direction
and speed they're moving at for instance
if the sun's ripples move
away from us they stretch out and give
off a reddish hue
if they move toward us they become
bunched up and bluish in color
with so much movement and activity on
the surface of the sun
it vibrates at many different
frequencies using a computer scientists
can translate the motion of the sun's
light waves
into sound waves which are then sped up
so that humans can hear them
this produces a sound similar to church
bells hitting several notes
simultaneously
as frequencies overlap and mush together
they create rhythmic bass thumps
over a constant background hum it's kind
of like a heartbeat
near a refrigerator so what if we could
actually hear the sun
with our own ears hypothetically if
space had an atmosphere like ours
how loud would the sun be here on earth
well due to the inverse square law
the sun's sound would travel outward in
all directions
meaning that the surface area of the
sun's sound would get larger
and larger as it emanates outward but
the number of watts per square meter
when the sound reaches
earth would be reduced to just 5
milliwatts
this is the equivalent of 90 decibels or
the sound of a motorcycle engine
right by your face it would feel like
being at a loud rock concert
all the time you'd probably want to
invest in some good earbuds
luckily we are over 150 million
kilometers away from the sun and
the sound it produces dissipates in
space over such a great distance
frankly i'd be more worried about having
to put up with the sound of a swarm of
giant mosquitoes
but that's a story for another
what if
you